qu'est ce qui se passe et tout va mieux
ça va mieux on est on est un peu
rassurés et ce qui se passe avec
elizabeth ii disons que hier a été très
interpellant déjà puisqu'on a appris
début d'après midi qu'elle a annulé son
entrevue avec boris johnson son nom et
le premier ministre on assure qu'on se
fasse en dix ans de règne on compte sur
les doigts d'une main le nombre de fois
où la reine n'a pas reçu le premier
ministre
non mais ça elle a annulé trois trucs un
bon elle annule un panneau le tennis un
jour et m'a bien on a appris dans le
courant de la journée à l'alcool à la
comaga cogite évidemment dans le courant
de la journée on a appris que son fils
cadet le prince édouard qui skie à st
moritz est rentré à londres donc là on
s'est dit on fait comment remonter
mécaniquement
et donc là on a commencé à avoir très
peur et alors cette nuit alors que je
dormais olemps le téléphone est devenu
fou natif des souvenirs ici on téléphone
et ckoi à céline donc ces lignes de
l'angleterre je 96 côté santé note save
the queen
[Musique]
ouais
énormément de notification qui en est
fait alors reprenez cette information
que la reine serait nord sera médias
américains en mesure qui agissent à un
média américain qui a dit ça
certains il faut des chewing gum j'ai
donc
nous on studio nous ont informé en
exclusivité que queen elizabeth est
décédé avec les dites moi donc
m'attacher juste je me suis pas inquiété
non honnêtement non moi je me suis dit
c'est pas possible je connais par coeur
le code qui va être mis en place le zii
landen breach code est ce que ça il va
se passer si elle si elle décède ah bah
c'est une opération militaire le jour où
elle décède a été décrétée derrière le
leader ni della sera le jour de son
décès et britt le dj dj dérive est
propre marc a bondi jamais le
débarquement si vous voulez vous dire
durant dix jours il va y avoir en deuil
national qui va se terminer par le 11e
jour où il y aura les funérailles d'état
qui seront à westminster mail j'ai pris
vraiment jour après jour ce qui va se
passer non mais juste bertrand est ce
qu'il est possible ça c'est la question
que tout le monde se doute que la reine
soit morte sans lui fera étape dans
l'est était personne ne le disons non à
tous les anciens pas dit la vérité mais
non c'est la vérité mais c'est écrit
bertrand
regardant bertrand sans rigoler parce
que moi c'est ce que tout le monde pense
et ça ça nous inquiète ce que moi je tu
connais un petit peu la reine
je connais la queen à elle avait une
boîte sur les champs
à la ferme et bien malheureusement le
courant il est au courant bah oui mais
adorer ces j'adorais cette boîte c'est
vrai beaucoup et on pouvait se pendre
vidéo
made bref allez voir on atterrit c'est
absolument impossible parce que selon
donc le london bychkov qu'est ce qui va
se passer à partir du moment formelle ou
si ruth masquer son militant chef sa 8e
balle sommet de sa forme et
du cobas ouais normal que le journaliste
est à partir du team
sont fait officiellement son décès il ya
tout un protocole qui va être mis aux
normes et durant quelques vous dire tout
de suite ou pas mais on se voit là
endurant tels que ça va falloir attendre
quelques heures et la bbc la première
qui va interrompre tous ces programmes
avec un écran noir de la musique funèbre
et c'est comme ça que nous le sommes
combatifs se passer pendant les
variations dans un peu dans le jeudi
mais oui que ma tin se passer pendant
les premières sort c'est surtout que si
le prince charest n'est pas présent aux
côtés de la reine il est le premier qui
va être informé par son secrétaire privé
qui s'auto mahut edouard cube et wariner
père de la reine il a appelé le prince
charles et il va lui dire london bridge
is doing
it is georges peuvent appeler me le dire
ce qui veut dire le pont de londres
vient de s'effondrer de ce décès en
quelques sortes et toi c'est le nom de
code l'environnement et des eyzies
saddam qui va vraiment être l'équivalent
des gras des carottes sont cuites
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
c'est important
c'est qu'il me regarde comme quoi la wii
sortie de boris johnson le second qui va
être prévenue blane avant tous les
autres simon doonan royal le premier
ministre et le premier ministre va alors
le faire savoir aux différents
ministères aux différentes chansons ou
qui en effet vont commencer à prévenir
d'abord les 54 états qui font partie du
coup ils doivent 54 personnes sur les 54
le monde
[Musique]
[Rires]
je vous appelle en pleine nuit que je
veux dire je raccroche aux
pisteurs parce que ça va être en cas de
marie précédent on attend déjà plus de
deux milliards de téléspectateurs
de l'autre sont déjà mis en qui va vu
des mesures exceptionnelles pour l'avoir
30 soumettre cet événement
dédié
ils voient qu'ils produisent à
fait moi aujourd'hui vous êtes en mesure
de nous dire que la reine est vivante la
reine est différent tu es absolument
puis c'est sûr aussi ring de ce fameux
code n'a nommé est ce qu est ce qu on a
ce qu'on a s'il ya eu cette rumeur
est-ce qu'il faut s'inquiéter est-ce que
son état et oui oui il faut s'inquiéter
oui absorberait les d'enceinte et à l
annuler l'entrevue avec le premier
ministre est là le coma depuis j'y serai
là presque 96 en forme la dernière photo
que mon avis c'était mercredi dernier
elle était déjà je voulais dire on peut
la revoir us en plus a fait c'est de
plus en plus du fait qu'elle est
affaiblie à l'état fasse bien elles
étaient courbés fidèlement la en ce
moment il est dans sa dans sa propriété
de clarence house il est à londres mais
lui aussi est un renard et comme il ya
également on a une famille roy tandis
brûlés
oui ça fausse note et qu'elle rentrait
du danemark où elle a mené une station à
cotonou oui parce que là on est ce qu
elle est à copenhague elle faisait
vouloir économiques et diplomatiques à
copenhague oui obama à copenhague je me
serais l'on va voir également c'est que
tous les drapeaux vont être mis en berne
avec overdrive et en grande tenue de
deuil qui va venir officiellement
accroché l'avis de décès aux grilles de
bmc qui va faire ça va être suivie dans
les deux heures qui vont suivre un
nathan est palpable à l'heure d'un
restaurant mais oui pour la vie raconte
le père noël est encore vivante
même et se régaler c'est une réponse est
vivante mais je vous assure quand même
que les fumeurs qui sont en charge des
windsor la société livre tanning et fils
mais j'ai déjà dit que bah voilà tout
est déjà ancrée
vivant le site américain est quand même
un site assez sérieux et que je vous
rappelle par exemple que karl lagerfeld
est mort à l'hôpital américain de paris
chanel a fait un démenti dans l'après
midi alors qu'il était mort il ya quand
même ne le savaient pas rassure d'octo
n'y a donc j'espère que tu t'es bien
renseignés tu es sûr de sûr de toi moi
je vais te dire est ce que tu fabriques
terre sainte et peur
je vais te dire tu la case oui
tu l'as vu de loin oui moi aussi j'ai vu
des gens
enfin et on dit pas arriver sûr qu'il va
venir est arrivé il va venir à rire la
question que l'on se pose c'est si le
prince trafic mais non tout le monde
connaît le code de compte ce qui aurait
pu se passer et ça nous y avons pensé
c'est que le média américain aurait été
le premier à diffuser la formation parce
qu'on sait déjà maman de diary amegan
non pas moyennant
la 6e ça ça ça tu me le dit
personnellement nous faire des tests sa
part de
jamais on vous imagine ce qu'il
s'apprête à faire mais il adore sa
grand-mère jamais il a répondu non
serment biographie
du bouchon dix jours au lieu
l'enterrement tu vois le web dix jours
il va rester ou la reine la con j'ai
les dents elle avait subi corps lequel
manquer la
demi-finale
windsor
qui va s'ébranler ont ramené le corps
salomon train tous les papas congères
c'est pas cartonné
déconne c'est pas donné l'arrêt sur un
cercueil de chêne anglais et de plomb
qui pèse une tonne à lui tout seul
l'état peut qu'à qui le portait un short
squeeze adore la
souplesse et messi